Thank You professor we work for an
extremely warm and generous introduction
and let me once more start by saying
what an honor it is to have been invited
to be the Abuja mystic fellow
at Columbia University thank you to
Professor partha chatterjee took a
village and to build character all the
arrangements that have been made here
this work I should see at the outset is
drawing on an archive that we have built
over the last four or five years as part
of a project organized by the German
Historical Institute and some of us have
seen you on education and poverty in
India when I think of eight centuries
let me start with two haunting images
from March 2015 which offer a vantage
point on the unique achievements and
contradictions of schooling in
contemporary India in one groups of
young men are desperately scaling
several storeys of an unplastered brick
building to assist students within to
answer a School Leaving Examination the
other newspaper image was of a father
who was sent to the lock-up overnight
for having tied his reluctant
six-year-old daughter to his period to
transport her to her maths exam both
images convey desperation of the
families particularly those that are
poor low caste and underprivileged in
clinging to what they see as the one
form of exit from their current
predicaments that is education or more
properly the vast system of
credentialing to which we give the name
schooling in India yet the second also
spoke of a pervasive reversion and
disgust rather than excitement and
eagerness as a reaction to the deadening
routines of study but an education may
not be what the family is worn from
schooling even
naturally India some aspects of the
reasons for these newsworthy aberrations
demand our preliminary attention all the
students concerned with girls the month
or AUP case figured a child one of five
on whom the father a security guard had
staked the hard-earned wait for private
schooling as the Gateway to a better
chance in life than he had enjoyed
invite surely be heard no such clear
link between education and employment
was evident the families of girls taking
the exam we're desperate to add
matriculation to the marriage ability
index of the school leavers Sanji seats
and manually chhoti among others have
noted that that education remains an
object of desire for very unexpected
reasons govt fears above the channels of
Manipur yupi that it shows how the
workings of literacy and education are
tightly linked to the widening of the
overall Democratic project in northern
Indian society which specifically
appeals to the Tamil and other the knit
communities these instances speak of
soaring expectations of schooling to
meet the new and ever-changing demands
of the marriage markets as a means of
escaping the dangerous boredom of
unskilled work as a route that leads to
the acquisition of a substance of the
common moral nature which though only
acquired by a minority is seen not only
as collectively shared but as acting on
an inherited identity yet we are also at
a time when the disenchantment with
Indian education are pronounced with
fervor and denunciations of the system
are the starting point of most scholarly
exercises only for inequality and its
effects to me also it's chief discovery
I would instead like to start at the
opposite end and return to to Roman's
that are already passing into the
archives of educational history I refer
to 1970s and 1980s when there were small
scale
that'll code from below in one case
facilitated by the indifference of the
states and in the other directly enabled
by it's the first refers to the sudden
growth of small alternative non-formal
schools in some parts of India inspired
and part of our ideas of Education that
we're drifting in from as far afield as
Italy Brazil and UK or from Indian
experiments with alternatives to schools
whether these ideas arose from
discontent for the systems of compulsory
education as in the UK in Italy all the
massive failures of the state as Brazil
they generated a focus on the methods of
learning as a way of ensuring students
went to school stayed there and
benefited from the experience the shape
of produced all kinds of normal exterior
experiments of Education largely in
places villages slums forests where
there was no viable demand for schooling
among these communities themselves non
formal schooling or alternative
education the only kind of schooling is
accessible to the poor nevertheless
opened up new possibilities and produced
unexpected results the second moment to
which I refer includes the unexpected
opportunities that emerge within the
interstices all the government school
system itself for those who were priced
crafts and classes I access their
experiences largely while the dossiers
of belem writings and autobiographies
that testament testified to this moment
of arrival when a new ballot language
was forged and here referring more or
less entirely to Kamata enabled in part
by systems of reservation and partly as
a consequence of the talented political
movement aravind modality is
autobiography entitled government
brahmana is a self-deprecating reference
to the largest of the state in providing
this opportunity to a great extent such
possibilities will generated by the
social endorsed Moses which marked the
government's classroom before they were
turned into ghettos of the
underprivileged with the rise of
at school take you together these two
very disparate sites are united in
representing the paradoxes thrown up by
democracy can imagine logic will focus
on the relatively minor experiments in a
vast sea of modernization provide us
it's something more than another means
by which we measure the failures of
Education against ever higher levels of
expectation not as instances of a
greater truth but as the fragments which
can be made to prise open the system as
an interpretive device the alternative
education experiments and the experience
of first generation beneficiaries of the
system of reservations both of which
generates with possibilities that
already belong to the past bear
testimony by two different ways of
narrating myself to the vastly altered
life chances offered by new modes of
recruitment to the classroom and there
may be some parallels here with the
predicament of our higher education
system today though they were fleeting
possibilities they allow us to think
anew to what extent was education
whether of the alternative or the
regular government school kind perceived
off as an opportunity and to what extent
a socializing force an asset opportunity
is receding
despite spur guarantee of education for
all krishnakumar has placed a moment
during the colonial period when the
teacher was turned into a meat dictator
both disempowered and curiously
retaining the worst of her pre-colonial
inheritance colonial education also
produced a new and exclusive excessive
reliance on the textbook which did not
really stand between the teacher and
student but dominated the classroom and
Melanie Gandhi in Tagore when two were
the only two thinkers who overcame a
fascination for revivalist educational
forms to systematically counter the
colonial
education system but their insights ran
aground in the post-independence period
however in the late 1960s and 1970s a
time of great political social ferment
in India there were two distinct kinds
of responses to very vivid failures of
mass education the more ambitious
attempt was to address the problems of
the system as in the motion about
science teaching program or modify dish
and later the a club a project which
were engaged in working with teachers
curriculum change and rewriting
textbooks there were also some micro
little experiments in the nineteen
seventies and eighties with alternative
schooling take enough to recover a more
meaningful learning experience the
centrality of the textbook in the
classroom was consciously replaced often
with bookmaking itself as a child center
project so this is just one of the
slides from from Philip mother
children's center but these are the
schools that I intend to discuss and
increase focus on the child and the
active use of crafts music terms and
reading in small intensely developed
classroom situations strengthen the
observation of both self and
surroundings
unlike mother Adele who literally ran
away from learning students of the
alternative schools were introduced for
pleasures of learning and we're far from
submerged by the anxieties of passing
exams of the series of experiments that
will be done among communities that had
little or no access to school I take
three examples from southern India a
slum school in Bengaluru a Dayton school
in silly pura called Sita school and his
father was he to releasing water not
another way our village is why not these
schools were run by outsiders to the
communities they served we're relatively
clear about what they saw the need of
these communities and were able to
sustain their efforts largely through
external financial aid and support let
us admit as the outset then the
impossibility of replicability on any
large scale but replicability was not
the interest of Margaret Katie
Buganda telethon of children center in
1938 Jen Psaki who started theater
school at 75 kg levy and activist and
writer who established canola in the mid
1990s these were multi age and mixed
ability schools usually with no more
than one classroom and not exceeding 40
or 50 students simply the desire to
preserve communities by nurturing
indigenous talents rather than replacing
them with national of ski touring skills
was also a motive these experiments were
empty aided by the neglect of the state
for instance schooling was not on offer
for adult Christians of Mali girl origin
some Hindus and Muslims in the village
sylvie pure as Jane sir he recalls
twenty-five years ago she says when
school was started most people were
still working within the village either
as agricultural laborers or as
construction workers many children at
that time we're not going to school the
school was started in part as a response
to remedy that and there are many things
that kept children away from school the
economic factors of course the fact that
there was no clear link between
education and employment and finally the
fact that the government school was a
rather joyless affair and had nothing to
attract the children themselves things
were not very different until another a
slump in the heart of Bengal where each
Margaret began her school the children
had norm Chows and clay on the streets
and pavements over any kind of school
and had no use for literacy except and
this is what drew them to her school
finally the interest in reading the
posters announcing the new releases of
NTR films every Friday in their
formative phase these alternative
schools or rather their middle class
where is peace with founders we're
reacting like those in many movements
worldwide to the problems of compulsory
schooling
an early statement to the alternative
school education group formed in the
1970s said we have come together
as a group of people who are concerned
about prison system school education and
about prevalent methods of teaching in
many schools the children seem to be
motivated chiefly by the fear of failure
in this month promotions etc formal
standards and a rigid timetable will
probably need to be replaced by flexible
age and ability groupings in the
children can work at their own speed and
according to their own interests we
would like to reduce the usual heavy
emphasis on book work and memorizing but
was it fair to assume that children who
have had no opportunity to attend any
school would benefit from an alternative
what is remembered of these remarkable
experiments in education by those who
were offered a new life through
schooling and I'm trying to reconstruct
that in most aggressive people the
allure of the well endowed classroom was
abundantly clear to those coming from
impoverished backgrounds the schools
offered books
themed crayons playthings were also
spaced song downs yoga classes and
freshly cooked meals few of the
interviewees spoke monstrous content to
their schooling except in the broadest
of terms but all shared a warm fuzzy
memory of the method and Balaton were
said it was a kind of non-formal school
no books no syllabus I did not by heart
anything in government schools on the
contrary he said they have to pass
that's all when he recalls that it was a
beautiful life he remembers a time of
relative freedom from scolding
punishment judgment and fear of failing
all hallmarks of the regular schools
freedom from which the students
cherished most
escucha mouths the tapenade I'm sorry of
the mother children center Nicole I
really had no interest for studies but
for us craft and craft class are very
dear in the heart
we should attend and learn something new
these are just a few slides Oh the
cathartic role of play
which was
to the ideas of education in Margaret's
school but also near artisans in this
Margaret's method resembled most
strongly the childhood display good
method of the Summerhill experiment I
distinguished said yes Neal one of the
most important experiments in
alternative education in the UK between
Wales and play to me football hockey
rugby and baseball are not real play
they lack the imagination of play when
children are free they tend to bypass
team games in favor of for want of a
better name fantasy 3 in a sprawling
slum like philipnaylor children dealt
through play with the coiled violence
before their blossoming sexuality the
stresses of an ambiguous morality in the
community and the constant economic
pressures of parents margaret discusses
with rare candle in her book which is
only open classroom the memories of
students however are far more muted in
the words of a student Oh Philip middle
school those days I used to get up and
come to school for nothing else but to
play with doors I felt it was a very
important job for me if I missed that
play I would feel sad the whole day as
if I had lost something I think that
clay has given me the strength to face
life today or as cannon put it recalling
the therapeutic value of play
clay was relief I wanted some security
I wanted to relieve pent up feelings I
wanted a place
I wanted a place which would accept me
shant Post describes the slow intuitive
work of learning through clay which he
adopted as a teacher in carnival so he
was student of animal energy later on
became its teacher we learnt it through
gills each child had a mind of their own
so there was no compulsion we were
compelled to do only very few things so
each did what he likes to do so the
little ones are given crayons and people
initially they would tear it all away
but gradually try drawing something then
gradually they may feel like writing
when they begin to get interested we
give them one letter to learn at first
they do not write the letters but later
on they do start to write learning
languages science and maths by doing was
valued thus as Vania Mary recalls in
other schools children learnt from what
teacher writes on the board but here we
have to feel like we have to see how the
tree is if they wanted to explain about
that he used to make us sit around the
tree and tell the story about that
school was thus an enchanting space and
Mallesons are minimalist he never missed
a single day in school from 8:30 to 5:00
on all we tease for those to whom evil
traditions of storytelling were unknown
since neither parents nor grandparents
had that kind of contact with children
the enchantment was consciously nurtured
through an insistence on what might be
described as the real media with
instruction in these alternative schools
the use of song dance drawing and
painting or creative writing to teach
subjects as varied as maths history and
science it enabled balachandra to make
his breakthrough as a professional
artist though not without considerable
interest in assistance of those who
recognize that talent
for more subtle the enchantments of
learning through play ended with the
elementary school alternative schooling
meant an exposure to an exploration of
their creative faculties for a brief
interregnum before most identity in face
to face with the economic constraints
which defined and indeed indeed denying
opportunities to pursue norm in cashable
skills although vallenari
acknowledged the value of her education
at seeker school where they used to
teach us in such a way that we were not
afraid of exams many did not make it
through SSLC that is the School Leaving
Certificate exam despite their best
efforts the very circumstances from
which not just cooling but trial indeed
self was snatched at a great premium
good sometimes proved insurmountable the
family was there for something that
could both enable and end the promise of
education many recall the pain arising
from the advertised adversities they
face and they regret not being able to
continue their education in most cases
because of family constraints a constant
elements of secrecy is involved many
women interviewees discuss PA hostak
took to continue their schooling without
social approval morally Christine
recounts repeatedly the massive
collective effort that is necessary for
the opportunity is a free schooling to
be grasped even by one child families
work very hard to keep their children in
school often at great cost
there is the economic burden of
schooling but there is also the physical
and emotional stress the real support
comes from the family and from the
community when children have to leave
because there is not enough money to
keep their in school or because they
cannot survive the hostility or because
they fail it is a matter of great
sadness for everybody
a great opportunity a huge investment of
skills Marcius money and much effort on
the part of many is lost
interrupted schooling was often met an
unusual pragmatism mumtaz of Sita school
who completed her
in her second attempt said everybody was
happy that I passed SSLC but after that
stay at home I was not motivated more
discouraged about studying home my
sister got married someone had to cook I
didn't ask my father about it I knew
they wouldn't affect things study and
there's the other except from memory as
well
puta ma of the tilith mother children
center could not complete certain
standard examination due to her
brother's marriage which became the sort
of holes and you can see that the the
the changing life circumstances of other
members of the family put pressure on
her not to continue with studies but to
begin working which was a sacrifice that
she did not feel she had ever got over
because she remembered it as a great
blunder I cheated myself she said I felt
very sad if I recollect how the teachers
advised me repeatedly to continue my
studies when I was receiving my transfer
certificate the withdrawal of family
support in each case abruptly ended the
brief window of opportunity that had
been opened up in their lives considered
a vehicle from Hashana birth who was
admitted to school only after great
insistence and she describes in a very
emotional way how she insisted on being
educated was opposed by every member of
her family completed her 8th class and
again denied that opportunity to
continue by a brother who said that
amongst us
no one has studied so much so what would
you do studying this much educated men
cannot be found in our caste then how
will you get married and so on and she
insists on studying further she sneaks
away to her school when others had gone
on their fishing business finally
admitted to school she found the courage
to overcome family resistance when she
suddenly saw herself as part of the
collective and this is how she remembers
the
moment so when I used to need the
prayers at assembly from there I saw
that there are almost 2,000 girls in the
girls school do they all come secretly
like me I'm wrong or they're wrong or my
family members are wrong who is wrong
then I realized that my family members
are wrong since 2000 girls are not a
small number if they are coming then why
shouldn't I
yet for these occur and it's a very
tragic story of thoughts because for her
the goal was Costigan government job
which still remains elusive improvement
of life chances for most was slighter
compared to crucial forms of resocialize
ation which resulted in the new
confidence and such the alternative
offered by these schools was less to
formal schools in education as to
structures of authority or forms of
domination in which these students were
embedded from family networks to
neighborhoods caste structures and
government programs the small glimpses
of those who try the state system and
felt compelled to leave serve as an
instructive comparison with the
alternative schools shaji bose was
admitted to a government Middle School
in Kerala
before coming to kanawa today a managing
trustee of the alternative school he
studied in he recalls it was after I
came here that I studied writing in
Malayalam without any mistakes
till my fourth standard in the
government school I was a fairly good
student but once here when I wrote one
sentence at least half of it had
mistakes that was when I had understood
that I did not know how to read and
write but there in the government school
everyone had simple phrases most reports
the good foundations they received and
the word foundation was always used in
English whether you were speaking in
Maryland or Canada or come they received
in equipping them less for jobs and
careers than to face life confidently
for those with an experience
of the most structured school space the
alternative school provided especially
in the junior years an environment in
which students felt encouraged rather
than judge accepted for their
differences rather than being reminded
of them Charlie boasts in particular
mentioned a great difference between
conventional school and the alternative
school like carnival I've had the
maximum problems when I went to that
government school it was the time when I
suffered the most of fascism when I
first came to Canada I could not hold a
decent conversation with anyone I was
that scared first issue was that health
care and second that I don't know how to
speak so we don't speak but now at least
we can speak to people face to face that
itself is much to speak of another
incidentally means dream the dreads of a
normal school were well known but
freedom from timetables textbooks and
like regularity could have been
meaningful only in places where they
were an actual alternative it could be
as in the slum setting where
unpredictability was the order of the
day that there was a yearning for
discipline order and structure content
of the Phillip mother children center
recalls that the most important aspect
of his alternative school life was the
discipline that it gave him compared to
the lack of discipline in his home a
time and place for everything every kind
of work be it bathing or cleaning the
vessels cleaning the plates after dinner
what should be done at water hour there
is a time for everything
getting up going to sleep eating
studying they should be disciplined this
is what he felt he lacked in his form
and the school would actually provided
an important sense of worth was
collected a cultivated in the
alternative school system which involved
children exclusively of one social of
course background they have interviews
therefore are singularly unmarked by
memories of humiliation etc and school
but here too the husband
shipped with parents no longer wishing
for that alternative if it reminded them
of forms of humiliation from which they
had already escaped as Ruth who now
teaches at FIFA school explain the
reasons for the reduced enthusiasm about
alternative schools these days said a
few parents object to the work like the
students have to clean their vessels
they should serve themselves food fill
water in the toilets so they don't want
their children to do it just study and
come can alternative schooling convince
children from the labouring classes
about the redeeming virtues of manual
labour schooling as we have seen at the
outset is seen as a means of distancing
themselves from manual work in
particular and therefore from entrenched
notions of humiliation there were some
early signs of an increasing impatience
with what was seen as a second-order
education and I'm going back in time a
little bit to speak of the education
ministers meeting in 1946 at which
Gandhi was also present and DC power
tables and academic administration in
Bombay presidency recounted the next day
a social worker from and upon amal
mother demanded in all seriousness
police protection for those responsible
for the implementation of Basic
Education everybody was intrigued by
this demand basic education means that
the children should look after the
cattle or sheep or do any cultural work
along with their parents he will have no
use for books of sweets or even a basic
craft or a school the villagers have
been irritated by the activities of this
kind of social worker they demand good
education for their children while these
social workers in Maharashtra want the
children to follow the parents
occupations instead of going to school
and the villagers attack them with
sticks and there have been cases and
another district where social workers
have been seriously injured
school is a space and these things come
true in many of these interviews an
unexpected space for both hope but also
new forms of humiliation this comes
through clearly in the interview with
shaji post on the cartoon Ike our
community community who recall the
unexpected humiliation and radical
estrangement that he felt when he
admitted he was admitted to a middle
school in Austin in Mullen Thoris isn't
why not
his Malaya and dialect was mocked at
parity leaving him with a strong desire
to return to the meagre comforts of his
tribal house therefore his admission to
Canada opened opportunities for escape
from customary humiliations of the
government school and this is how he
describes how he leads the government
school and hostel the next week when my
mother came to see me I told her I would
no more study here under any condition I
was not even keen to get my bag in
package once I saw mother I went home
right from the very road where I met my
mother we did not have an education in
mind once we came back and not just that
some eight students discontinued along
with us in the very same week and even
walked home at night that shotty forces
experienced ended more happily in
carnival was a stroke of good fortune
compared to the routine impressions
faced by some in the government school
company Ramaiah a well-known Kannada
writer recalls his brother's travails I
was the first person he says from either
side of the family to have completed
high school but before me my brother
wheels nalebuff
had also attended high school he wasn't
tractive in well girls young man
straightforward and outspoken this
attitude was considered arrogant and
hadn't earned him the antagonism of
several teachers as a result they failed
my brother twice in the eighth class for
no reason my brother who knew this to be
the work of some Costas teachers burnt
with
to the side but suffered helplessly my
father who couldn't take my brother's
suffering creeds to all the gods
possible made all kinds of offerings and
poachers but nothing seemed to work
finally my father made the mighty effort
when I rolled my brother back in high
school he would skip school and spend
most of these sitting on the walls for
only to Marie's new lake one day my
brother didn't officer whom somebody
noticed a dead body floating around in
the lake cast was therefore in these
accounts not experienced as a remnant of
the past so much as a contemporary form
of power not a traditional taboo but a
modern stigma the violence of the school
to which many of balith autobiographies
and my stories bore testimony was as
much epistemological as in the crucial
question of languages that were lost or
killed in the process of schooling in
some alternative schools which were open
in the 70s a tense for me to introduce
the child to the literary heritage of
Indian languages as well as the power of
English in conceptualizing new
disciplines so the science and maths
were taught in english and literature
humanities in the local language
but in mostly through the demands of
learning a new language placed a
crippling burden on some in these
Exponential's one hears the
contradictory consequences of masculine
uniformity and the imperatives of
learning English which could be
experienced as loss and estrangement as
many have pointed out English in India
is not just a language it is at one at
the same time of judicial legal
apparatus it is a political system it is
a semiotics of modernity it is a
substance that even defies and exceeds
the use of terms like cultural capital
english' status as an internationally is
monic language and it's kinship with
computer literacy as a reference
success was recognized even among those
who passed through the alternative
schools during his long interview Cullen
who had studied in the Philippines our
children center repeatedly returned to
the question of language and its meaning
as a form of capital in contemporary
India speaking in Canada and not his
mother tongue family which was the
language which he had mastered through
his years in school he reveals a very
different attitude to the question of
language when it came to his own three
children a deep desire that he must give
his children and opportunity I never got
mainly English he repeated his repeated
assertions was it his eldest child in
most court good enough marks to get into
a good program in college we need a
certificate but degree in our hands in
English said his wife
pochamma also a student at another
school everything becomes different even
so there was nothing more than uneven
access to English as powers or elite of
any languages power within a system in
which completely serenity Buddhist
circumstances were allowed to play a
formative role in self definition in the
decades immediately after independence
the incomplete absorption of the poor
Indian family into the archives of the
state allow unique opportunities for
redefinition social revenge the
encounter with public naming and
leeching of birth in order to enter
school gave rise to an unexpected
clarity about the stealing of the name
and the sharing of reconstructing one's
origins the compulsion of providing read
inventing a date of birth to sits the
seventh or the tenth 7 exam became an
opportunity in the case of Satine arena
this failure to maintain records was
turned to opportunity the opportunity of
passing an upper caste I was happy he
says that my headmaster was showing such
concern for me and in something as
personal as a name he will always take
keen interest in his pupils sometimes
with the parents approval
he changed the names of students if in
terms of caste
it seemed to represent something
contemptible in my case the suffix Arya
gave away my cost it was in the 90s
entered in that I became sati naina
he was Sofia but he became I just see by
way of an aside that both sangria and a
corner policy through Maya changed their
names from ready to I at a time when the
Dalit movement of Karnataka was taking
shape galvanized by the Moussa education
the school and university hostel in
particular became a sight popular to
sensation entering the school and
staying there despite the humiliations
and scarcities of the time was an
additional challenge schooling was
simultaneously an escape from
humiliations and a renewed experience of
existing ones not only where their
separate school several slaves practices
water but there was open discrimination
against those weapons Circuit considered
unteachable in such a situation to pass
the school leaving exam in one attempt
was a rare achievement professor of
English KD Sevilla also Canada poet and
activist of the Hunger savatthi has said
there were others from all communities
who had passed but no one had forgot
through in the first attempt including
the headman's son with this achievement
I became the hero of the village that
was piggy indeed as many tons of the
biographies have shown the desire for
schooling particularly amongst deprived
classes and classes is often quite is
quite often a desire for participation
and presence in existing systems of
Education a longing for structure form
predictability but rather than freedom
and experiencial
modes of learning such opportunities
were seized with
but in many cases this would not have
been possible without the aid of another
figure there was always if you read the
biographies you will see this with all
these and enlightened or not so
enlightened individual who helps the
lower castes a party a Brandon teacher a
schanberg a tuition teacher
protege children recalls that while he
was in high school his County teachers
were an important influence they need us
read a lot he says including classical
Tamil poetry I was encouraged to
participate in oratory competitions ravi
kumar was inspired by a brilliant
teacher Exeter he developed an interest
in modern comic poets such as party
Larsen and even practice writing
metrical poet even following this
teachers suggestions but all of these
are very sort of accidental moments in
the schooling to which these people who
later on become majors and it's writers
testified in uses of literacy Richard
Hoggart offered a sobering picture of
the loneliness of the school scholarship
boy he has to be more and more alone if
he is going to get on there is unlikely
to be a room of his own the boy has to
cut himself off mentally so as to do his
homework as well as he can
it is a bleak and inhospitable world
that scholarship boy encounters a three
shanku like satyrs between two worlds
one lid the other powerless to be born
in India - for those born in the 1950s
and growing up in the 60s the london
school offered ambience of the charities
ages in part by the challenges of
multicast multicast classrooms with this
new minority of Dalits in German schools
develop a new criticality towards the
societies they struggled in and against
I would say that the radical
estrangement was a true or description
of the reservation students in India of
the sixties and seventies if they
blossomed forth to produce an
astonishing use of language in the form
of the
writing it was more correctly due to
Dulles awakening in the largest city
then to the methods in the classroom
compare ballets and Recife school who
not only existed his village and his
class status but by migration to England
and marriage to an English woman
darkness itself and sales today actually
I had forgotten that I am a parents the
enraged poetry of his youth as in his
volume funny literally the one who
voices of which he was justly proud had
transformed itself into a certain pride
in exiting that space altogether and he
says born as a Dalit I am now a British
citizen the challenges to the
alternative schools and to any kind of
alternative to what goes on within
school walls have been exacerbated by
the transformations within slum village
and forest societies all of which are no
longer insulators either from the
pressures of the markets the agencies of
the state or the operation of democracy
Adama division was so impressed with
Conover that he invited easy BPG baby to
start at least fifty such branches with
government aid and offer however that
could not be accepted even imagining an
ideal scenario in which this is possible
what hope is there countering the more
powerful pull of private English
education this is what Margaret says
about Philip and today where the desire
for schooling has triumphed over an
interest in education finished showing
you some very quickly a few images from
the late 70s all the school in the
family area but this is what looking
back says today almost all the children
who are roaming about from the streets
in the 70s and 80s are sending their
children to private schools and English
medium schools where our PHP eights
na is so interested in doing more and
more exams to get more degrees but the
quality of education is very poor most
parents want their child to be a good
education which they didn't get earlier
we had more freedom to start alternative
schools we worked independently from the
government system the word alternative
is not relevant anymore there is need
for educational inputs but we have to
work in another form and not through
alternative schools now we should not
think of alternative or supplementary
education but welcome improving the
quality of overall education of the
system what has definitely changed since
at least early 1990s are the options
available to the poor and the
marginalized as G in fact it says
education was not a commercial venture
in 1970s so the government was least
interested in ensuring the economically
weak by going to schools of any kind
also there was no automatic promotion so
parents and children anticipated failure
and retention nevertheless the glimpses
of an alternative render such terms of
success or failure entirely
inappropriate transformed family
fortunes and expectations there are two
openings amperes revealed as well as
government hostility greatly reduced the
chance of even thinking a clavier for
instance which systematically scaled up
the activity based highly centered model
that it had pioneered ran aground when
the NP government insisted on local
government sector sanction citing the
73rd amendment as roughly polymer
recalls the government assumes that it
done
assumed that it did not require local
recommendations for the rote learning
curriculum it used because it was the
agency with an electoral mandate and
hence could do what things fit but
nevertheless it insisted but equal areas
seek the assent of parents under the
73rd amendment in order to sanction
their program so of course the ocean bar
experiment was closed in 2008
and despite this despite the fact that
there were hundreds of students parents
intellectuals teachers who wrote letters
to the government and sign petitions
protesting the closure of a science
program and a weaker yet said and the
demand that it be reinstated what do
these historical miniatures glimpses of
possible uses of literacy in enabling
and escape from the drudgery in
objection of low-cost classes tell us
about the very different possibilities
that were opened up both in alternative
and government schools in the 70s and
80s as krishnakumar noted even the High
Noon have never never be in modernity
did not build a credible and lasting
peace for the expansion of elementary
education the task of welding a nation
was severely checkmated by the continued
operation in the usefulness of caste
class ethnic and gender divisions which
had served our economy and society so
well only to be recently challenged by
the operational democracy in one hand
and the demands of market and
credentials on the other the desire for
the enabling opportunities for English
when the rights to education was finally
guaranteed in 2009 it was when
privatization of Education had already
become an irreversible fact the
possibility of a common schooling
education which brought together mixed
abilities and backgrounds where
opportunities that were briefly
available to those who attend in the
public school system in the 1670s our
interviews revealed a much more
precarious future for those who pass
through alternative schools and Bharat
Sandra says I wouldn't have written it's
all because of Sita school I don't know
what I will be in today how do i studied
somewhere else today
if alternative pedagogy is our source at
all it is by those already well and
doubt the cultural capital that will
define and determine their life chances
and I have to say that van Lowe is
probably one of the few locations where
there is a proliferation of alternative
occasional experiments for middle and
upper-class children it may lead
memories of the reservation student then
that give us greater hope speaking over
time and the space in school and larger
political awakening intersected to
produce a new critical and vibrant
cultural intervention at the same time
the memories are both students who
attended alternative schools and those
who found a foothold in the public
school illustrate how blinding the
ideology of individualized hard work a
form of media ISM can be can be in
obscuring the roots of structural
inequalities often those inequalities
were revealed only by the intersections
of educational processes and political
movements until then as many done photo
biographies tell us only the for tutors
encounter with the enlightened we
usually upper caste churn usually is
interventions enable the break from the
grinding inequalities of the structure
and the passage of some ballots into
higher education not all forms of
political engagement produce the same
effects as the ballot movement
informatica for sale alone the true
democratic awakening came from a much
more individual engagement with the
newspaper and the book rather than
classroom activism and he says if I talk
about the manner of gaining knowledge
there is the are demonic through a
library a public library so I had
membership stage so I would go there and
read books another thing was even if for
if it was by hard work mother would
subscribe to the newspaper from the time
when I was studying in third standard on
all days there were only two houses that
had subscribed to the newspaper at that
time as far as I was concerned that is
how I got an awareness about things
initiative yet for some and the tamerica
ballots the emergence of the lithography
itself today in thisaway was the first
flowering of both politics
hope not for nothing does here a Maya
speak of the DSS as a big school also a
university a real University the
question you need to ask today he says
is what made it a place of real
education far from it being a
consequence of individuated struggles
within the space soil alternative
schools which were achievements of a
different order these three groups
struggles within the space of an
enabling state however flawed blossomed
into new a new cultural force whose
effects are still with us today thank
you
[Applause]